hey have you ever wanted to build an
image search app yeah but I have no idea
where to start well it's actually pretty
simple here's what you need to do first
you upload all of your images into cloud
storage okay got it what's next next you
need to set up a pub sub service that
triggers an image notification to a
cloud run service interesting what's the
cloud run service for the cloud run
service calls the vision API or custom
automl API that you create and this API
will then help you identify and label
the images that sounds pretty powerful
but how do the users search the images
great question the users can search the
images on the cloud run service itself
it's that simple wow I had no idea
building an image search app could be so
easy thanks for the tips no problem now
go give it a try